[Music]
I'm very often asked what is the
Darwinian survival value of religion and
I usually reply that maybe the wrong
question you may have to rephrase the
question and it may turn out to be not
the survival value of religion but the
survival value of something else in the
brain which shows us that manifests
itself as religion under the right
circumstances now a good analogy which
I've used is the question why do moths
fly into candle flames now you could
describe that behavior as suicidal
behavior in moths self-immolation
behavior in moths camicazi behavior in
moths that would be one way of phrasing
the question but it's the wrong question
if you actually look at the way moths
and insect eyes generally work insects
use celestial objects like the Sun or
the moon or the Stars as compasses it's
important it's valuable that there is
survival value for any animal in moving
in a straight line
if an animal wants to move in a straight
line a very good way to do it is to keep
a celestial object at a fixed angle and
that's easy to do in insects because
they have compound eyes where very
unlike our eyes where the eyes as a
whole it's a lot of hemisphere little
tubes looking outwards and so you can
maintain a fixed angle to something like
a star or the moon by keeping the moon
in one or more tedium if you do that
because rays from the moon come from
optical Infinity they are parallel and
so if you keep the moon in one or more
tedium you will fly in a straight line
it might be say 30 degrees keep the moon
at 30 degrees to your right and that
works and that's valuable and that's
what many insects do however candles are
not at optical infinity candles are
close the rays of light from a candle
are therefore not parallel they're
radiating out if you maintain a fixed
angle of say 30 degrees - the rays that
are emitted from a candle you will
describe a neat logarithmic spiral into
the candle flame
kill yourself so these moths are not
killing themselves they're not it's not
serious
idle behavior it's a misfiring of a
natural normal behavior which before the
invention of candles would have worked
and it still does work the vast majority
of time because most of the time in the
dark a mother is not subjected to
artificial light so ask the right
question the right question is not
what's the survival value of suicidal
behavior in moths the right question is
what's the survival value of maintaining
a fixed angle to a celestial object and
then you it's easy to come up with the
right answer
proximate questions are questions of
which you answer with the form the
physiology of the animal the nervous
system of the animal the hormones of the
animal things happen in the animals
nervous system would cause it to do
something that's the proximal answer the
ultimate question is what's the survival
value what's the benefit to the animal
what's the benefit of the animals genes
in particular to make it do that an old
teacher of mine at Oxford junior Baker
used to use the example of breeding
seasons in birds why do why do burrs
breed at certain times of year the
ultimate answer is it's beneficial to
them to have breeding seasons because
they produce chicks at the right time of
year to cash in on the optimal food
supply that's the ultimate answer the
proximate answer is that they breed at a
certain time of year because day length
is changing and their hormonal system
their nervous system is geared to day
length and that's the proximal reason
why they breed at a certain time
you
[Music]